who is insecure about their shortness  and height me you're insecure about your  height yeah why I'm not allowed to do  you think I'm short I think you're  shorter than Bart  stand up I wish I was like  can you go back to back  we're about the same height can you guys  both cry real quick yeah I cry about it  right five eight five seven I wish I was  taller sometimes yeah you're not short  no you fall short of expectation but  you're not sure what's your dream height  your dream height no strings attached  I'm not insecure about my high boat I do  know some guys that are bar and it I do  know people that like wear shoes that  have thicker soles like guys  specifically to appear taller  no